[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Great,
thank you, and welcome.
I'm so excited.
I've never been to
this Google office,
and this is totally cool.
It's nice to see everyone
here today, and a nice crowd,
packed house.
Congratulations,
Women Techmakers.
Appreciate that.
So I'm going to go down
and start with Saron.
What we'll do is just
introduce yourselves,
what you're doing right
now, and then we'll
get started with
a few questions.
SARON YITBAREK: Sure.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Saron.
So I have two jobs.
Here I'm representing
CodeNewbie.
I'm the founder.
We are the most
supportive community
of programmers and
people learning to code.
We have a weekly Twitter chat.
I'm the host of a
weekly podcast called
the CodeNewbie podcast, which
you should all subscribe to.
And then in my day job, I
actually work at Microsoft.
I'm a program manager for
a new technical training
program called Tech
Jobs Academy, where
we offer four months of free
education and technical skills
for unemployed and
underemployed New Yorkers.
And applications are open, so if
you know anyone, let them know.
They go to techjobsacademy.com.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Shanna?
SHANNA GREGORY: Yeah.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Shanna.
I am the dean of
Grace Hopper Academy,
which is in the middle
of the first class.
Those of you who are familiar
with web development programs,
it's an immersive 13-week
program here in New York City.
It's the only program in
New York that's for women,
and our tuition model
is that the women
will pay once they get jobs.
So trying to create
the opportunity
for those who are financially
restricted from things
like this.
Very excited to be here.
I have a background in
working in coding boot camps,
and some of my students from
Fullstack Academy are here.
Very excited to
see them here now
that they're kind of flourishing
as female developers.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Rebecca?
REBECCA GARCIA: Hi, everyone.
Good morning.
My name is Rebecca Garcia.
I'm the co-founder of a
nonprofit called CoderDojo NYC.
And it's part of a global
movement of free coding
clubs for youth, where we
do one-on-one mentorship
in mini hackathon-style
workshops once a month for web,
game, and app development.
And we also have girls' programs
and longer-term programs
for advanced iOS, Android app
development, JavaScript, things
like that, which are all free.
And my day job is I
am the technical head
of product at a data API
company called Next Caller.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: And
not least, but Christina.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Do
I need a microphone?
Oh.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Yeah.
CHRISTINA MORILLO:
So hi, everyone.
My name is Christina Morillo.
I'm also on Twitter
as @divinetechiegirl.
I know a few of you have said
hello to me this morning.
So I'm happy to be here.
I'm one of the co-founders of
Women of Color in Tech Chat.
So we're pretty much a
supportive community of women
and non-binary people
in the tech industry.
And we're also the creators
of the Women of Color
in Tech Chat Stock Photos.
So if you want to
have our stock photos,
you can just search Women
of Color in Tech Chat,
and you'll see our stock photos.
They're also on Flickr.
During the day, I'm
actually vice president
of technology and information
risk at Morgan Stanley.
But don't tell them I told you.
They're very strict.
So anyway, I wanted
to be here, which
pretty much means I'm part of
the information security team.
So I'm more of a information
sec, data security engineer.
And I'm very happy to be here.
Oh, and I also have three kids.
So I feel your pain, girl.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: And I am Rose
Robinson again with the Anita
Borg Institute.
I manage all of our communities.
That includes Systers, our
ABI.Local, our Grace Hopper
conference, as well as our
open-source communities,
which I'll talk about
a little bit later.
It's really great
that Heather talked
about the last piece of the
white elephant opportunities
because that's actually
what this panel is about.
It's actually women creating
opportunities in tech.
And we'll hear about
some of the opportunities
that they've mentioned already.
But let's get started with maybe
just creating opportunities
for yourself in your career.
Saron, do you want
to start us off?
SARON YITBAREK: Sure.
Am I gonna go first
on every question?
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Yeah.
SARON YITBAREK: That's fine.
That's what I get for
being on this side.
So creating
opportunities for myself.
I think the biggest thing has
been to always raise my hand
when opportunities arise.
A great example of
that is-- are you
all familiar with RailsConf?
Show of hands?
So it's a really big-- I
think one of the biggest--
conferences for Rails
developers, and I'm a Rails
developer by trade.
And I saw this conference,
and I heard from a friend
that she was organizing a
different conference called
RubyConf.
And I thought, man,
that's really cool.
I didn't think that that was
a thing that you could do.
And so I just cold-emailed
one of the organizers.
And I said, hey, I'd love
to be a part of this.
Any help you need,
I would love to be
a part of this organization.
And this current
RailsConf, they invited
me to be on the
programming committee.
So I got to review all the
talks and make recommendations.
And I'm running
two of the tracks.
And so for me,
creating opportunities
has been about seeing
what other people are
doing-- men or
women-- and seeing
great opportunities
and really great things
going on, and raising
my hand and saying,
I'd really like to
be a part of that,
and not waiting to be asked, and
not waiting for an invitation.
ROSARIO ROBINSON:
Yeah, thank you.
SHANNA GREGORY: Yeah,
that's really great.
I think for me, it's
finding one thing
that I can convince
myself I'm very good at.
So starting out, I come from
creative writing and literature
background.
The one thing I thought I was
good at coming out of college
was writing emails.
So I found the job that I
could write the best emails.
And that kind of
snowballed from there.
I ended up helping
people write resumes
and creating their own stories
and narratives for becoming
developers specifically.
I became very good at
helping people find a job,
and that is something that
wins you a lot of favors.
And people are
very, very excited
when you're helping them prepare
for interviews and all of that.
And just taking one thing
and becoming good at it,
and just allowing that to turn
into more and more and bigger
and bigger, and taking
on more responsibilities
and allowing yourself to attract
more skills and build that up,
it just has to start with
one very small thing.
If you're very good at writing
emails, you can go from there.
Email as many people
as you want to.
Make it as creative as you'd
like to, and then kind of allow
yourself to accept
whatever opportunities
are coming your way.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: And Rebecca?
REBECCA GARCIA: So I'm
a really big believer
in personal branding and sharing
what you're passionate about.
And so that doesn't
necessarily mean being like,
I have to share every single
thing that I eat on Twitter.
Like, that's what everybody
wants to hear about.
I think it's a matter of
your unique blend of what
you care about.
And so I talk a lot about
mindfulness and technology
and yoga and this mix
of my own personality.
And I've kind of let that
blend into other opportunities.
So I blog.
I'm also on Twitter
@geekgirlweb.
And it's opened so
many doors for me.
Twitter by itself, I've gotten
a roommate from Twitter.
I've gotten speaking
opportunities
to go abroad from Twitter,
from people that I've met.
That's, I believe, how we
met originally, as well.
Did we also meet off Twitter?
We also met off Twitter.
So I am a huge believer in
putting yourself out there
and also finding those
opportunities for yourself
and really being able to
create yourself and create
those opportunities through
putting yourself out there.
And it can be really scary
because by default, I'm
an introvert.
And now I do a lot
of public speaking.
And I think it's
brought me a lot of joy
to share my stories
with other people,
and hopefully then in
turn inspire other people.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Thank you.
Yeah, we did meet on Twitter.
Yeah.
So I forgot to
mention one thing.
I'm also the community
manager for CodeNewbie.
So I work with Saron.
SARON YITBAREK:
And she's amazing.
Amazing.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: In
boosting the brand.
And that was a white
elephant opportunity
because when she asked
me, I was like, why?
SARON YITBAREK: I had no
idea she felt this way.
CHRISTINA MORILLO:
Meaning, like, why me?
But anyway, so I'm a big
believer in community,
very big believer in community.
I feel like we need each other.
We need to support each other.
And when Heather mentioned
giving opportunities
to other people,
being a connector,
I'm very big on that.
That's just capital
me, connector, right?
But another thing I'm big on is
taking action, so taking things
into your own hands.
If you see a problem
that you think
you may be able to contribute
to, contribute to it.
Don't wait for
anyone's validation,
or don't wait for anyone to
give you the OK or the go-ahead.
There's a problem.
Try to fix it, contribute.
That's it.
That's an opportunity, right?
So just a quick
example-- when I was
building the website for
Women of Color in Tech Chat,
I didn't see any stock images
of people that looked like me.
And I've been in the tech
industry for over 17 years.
And I didn't feel like
taking a selfie that night
because my hair was a mess.
So anyways, I decided-- out
of anger, I started tweeting,
I wish I could just
hire a photographer
and get some women of
color in technology
and take some photos.
And then I said, wait, I
could hire a photographer
and get some women in
technology and take some photos.
And so one of the things for
me is that anger activates.
So usually, like
I said, if there's
a problem that makes
you angry, by you
activating it and just realizing
it, you can take action on it.
So I say that's one way
to create opportunities.
And also by being
present and listening.
Become a good
listener, because a lot
of times when you listen to
people instead of talking
so much about what
you think or you
feel-- which is also important.
But if you listen
to other people,
you will hear what
opportunities they may
have that they don't even know.
So someone like Shanna
could be listening
to me complain
about I need a job
and I need to update my resume.
She could say, well,
hey, I'm really
good at updating resumes.
And she's just created
an opportunity herself.
So just kind of
working together.
And that's the best
part of community.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: So I
can add to that, as well.
And I have a similar
story as Heather,
as well, because I was in
a career and had two kids
and really wasn't
planning for two kids.
But all through school, I was
the only woman in my class.
I majored in math
and computer science.
And particularly
in grad school, I
was also the only
person of color.
So to have those two, gender
and race, to challenge,
it was pretty hard.
And what I did is really--
how I created opportunities
for myself was to
give myself a voice
and just make sure that I am
heard, that my issues matter
to everyone.
And so that was really
important for me
in creating opportunities for
myself, but also to others.
Sometimes when you're out
there speaking on Twitter,
you're giving others
permission-- and not
only permission, but letting
people know that it's OK.
That you're not alone.
That's one of our communities
at Anita Borg Institute.
It's really the flagship
that started the institute,
was Systers.
And Systers is really just
supporting women in technology
across the globe, similar
to what Women Techmakers is
doing right now, as well.
So we really partner
really well together.
So let's talk about some
of the opportunities
that you are involved in
that create opportunities
for other women in tech.
And why don't-- I'm not
going to start with you.
I'm going to start with
Christina this time.
Christina?
CHRISTINA MORILLO: OK.
So this is the last time
I'll talk about the photos.
But they're very important
because representation matters.
And now our photos
are on TechCrunch.
And the reason why
I'm bringing them up
is because of the fact
that I know of, confirmed,
one of the women that was
featured actually got a job.
She got hired by GitHub.
And the reason was because
she was at a conference.
And she's actually in
the room, but I'm not
gonna shout her out.
So I believe the story goes
that she was at a conference,
and someone recognized her.
And they started-- he was
like, were you in the photos?
And she said yes or something.
And they sparked
up a conversation.
And they started talking.
And if you find her, you can
talk to her about it some more.
But when she told me
that, I was really
taken aback because
I just thought I was
solving a problem for myself.
And I had no idea
that it could span
across different
people and different--
so it was not only
about the photos.
It was about so much more.
So yeah, I don't know if
that answers the questions.
ROSARIO ROBINSON:
Yeah, absolutely.
I think-- and this is
the last time we'll
talk about the photos, really.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: I'll try.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: No.
But your photos actually gave
the industry an in into, OK,
well, this is important.
So we need to make sure
that we have representation
across the board.
And now, you see your photos
on TechCrunch and Huffington
Post, all of the online.
So you got to give it up
for Women of Color in Tech.
[APPLAUSE]
I mean, that's exactly
what voices do.
And we appreciate that.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Thank you.
OK.
I'll just say there's a
brand new batch coming out
this month.
That's it.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Rebecca?
REBECCA GARCIA: Awesome.
How come I didn't get that deal
out of being in the photos?
I didn't get a job out of it.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: But you
were on TechCrunch and a lot
of other sites, right?
REBECCA GARCIA: Oh, I guess so.
We'll see.
I'm teasing.
Yeah, so I think
through CoderDojo NYC,
I feel in a similar
way of seeing a need
and wanting to help others.
I actually co-founded CoderDojo
NYC because when I was younger,
I had the opportunity to
go to a computer camp.
And my sister
sponsored me to go.
And I slept on her
couch the whole summer
in what I call indentured
servitude of babysitting.
Because I babysat,
and she sponsored
me to go to a
computer camp at MIT.
And I later went
to that program.
I went and I returned to
teach at that program.
And when I came
to New York, there
weren't any programs
like that that
were accessible to families.
The program I had gone
to was $1,000 a week,
not including food
or accommodations.
And it's still very expensive.
And it's a really
fantastic program,
but it was inaccessible.
And I heard about CoderDojo,
and I tweeted at them.
And I said, hey, is there
a chapter in New York?
I would love to help out.
And they're like, no,
but you can start one.
Found my other
co-founder on Twitter.
We met up for coffee, decided
that we weren't serial killers.
And then we co-founded
CoderDojo NYC.
And it's been this
amazing opportunity
to bring technology
education that's
coed to both boys and girls.
And to me, diversity
isn't just seeing--
I think it's really
important to get more women
and to get more
minorities in technology.
But to me, the
answer to diversity
is having everyone
together in the same room,
where it becomes normal
to have everyone together.
And so not only providing
opportunities to youth,
but also the chance to mentor.
So having more women mentor.
And we're really proud of
our naturally-occurring 50/50
gender ratio and ethnic
diversity at our programs.
And so that for me has been
the best way to give back.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Yeah.
Shanna.
SHANNA GREGORY: I would
echo a lot of what everyone
is saying about community.
When I came to New York for
a job from the Bay Area,
I had no network
and no community
and a very, very small
handful of friends.
So I started going to meetups
and meeting with, specifically,
Women Who Code NYC.
[CHEER]
Yeah.
I'm trying to find the
person who said that,
so I can-- oh, hey.
But yeah, that really gave me
insight into how many women
in New York City are in
technology, or the small sample
size that we had there.
There are now over 5,000
members in our chapter, which
is very exciting.
But the ones who
are learning how
to code, what their
problems are--
what are you encountering?
What is stopping you
from participating
in education programs?
Or what is stopping you
from teaching yourself?
Is it mentorship?
Is it financial?
Is it all of the above?
Is it a representation
in technology,
that you don't see yourself
in "Silicon Valley," the show?
So that's stopping you
from thinking that that is
a viable route for you to take?
So really collecting all of
the information from people
and having conversations
and getting
to meet so many amazing
women who really need
the opportunity
presented to them,
and encouragement and help and
mentorship and all of that,
really inspired the creation
of Grace Hopper Academy.
It wasn't that we were hoping
to take the female students
that we had at Fullstack
Academy and put them
in our own experimental program.
It's still a coed
program, but it's
being able to give the
same level of education,
the same opportunities, to
women who otherwise were being
held back from participating.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Saron?
SARON YITBAREK:
So at CodeNewbie,
we don't have a diversity goal.
We have a mission of inclusion.
And so for me, my
goal has never been
to be in a room full of
people who look like me.
My goal has always been to
be in a room full of people
who look so different that what
I look like doesn't matter,
so that it's my ideas
and my skills that
are the most important thing.
And so with CodeNewbie,
I feel very,
very privileged to
have the opportunity
to pick the people
that I work with
and to pick the voices
that I get to amplify.
And so we have a weekly podcast.
We've done 77 episodes.
And every single time I pick a
guest, I'm thinking about, OK,
by picking this person,
what message am I sending?
And I think that
when a lot of people
pick their leadership teams
and pick their speaker panels
and pick the people they
really put up on a pedestal,
I don't think they are
always aware that they're
sending a message.
If you have a leadership
team and it's all white guys,
you're sending a message.
You may not mean to.
You may not want to.
But you are.
And it's all those
little messages
that tell a story of
who should be here.
And so when I get to pick
who my guests are, and I
get to pick whose stories
to tell, I'm thinking,
OK, if I have
gender balance, I'm
sending a positive message
of who gets to be here.
If I'm taking more
international people, which
I'm making a huge effort
to, I'm sending a message
of who gets to be here.
And so it's about me being
very purposeful with who
I pick for my community manager,
who I pick for my team leads,
who I pick on the show, and
being mindful that every time I
pick someone, I'm
contributing to the story
and making sure that the
story is incredibly inclusive.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
That's awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
So in the opportunities that
you are working on right now,
how can you share some of those
stories of the opportunities
for women in tech, particularly?
How have they impacted
those particular women?
And is that on a global scale?
Is that on a local scale?
Or more in tech
or more training?
Yeah, I'm gonna to start with--
I'm actually going to start
with Rebecca this time.
REBECCA GARCIA: All righty.
So two quick stories
that I want to share
from some of the girls who
come out of our programs.
And the idea behind
CoderDojo NYC, I think,
is creativity,
collaboration through code,
being able to do
that through code,
and whatever excited you
when you were younger.
And our goal isn't to make the
next big tech star, whoever.
It's more of if we can instill
that excitement of learning
in you, then that's great.
Or if you ended up not
liking programming,
now you know before you get to
college what you didn't like.
And so I had that experience.
I thought that I wanted to make
video games when I was younger.
And then I actually
tried to do it,
and I was like, oh,
this is really hard.
I don't want to do that.
And that's what I did at
the summer program at MIT
that I went to
when I was younger.
And one of our girls, one of
the first girls who joined us,
she was with us
for a few months.
And her parents
eventually approached us.
And she started to get
more and more interested
and started doing HTML and CSS.
And her parents came
up to us and said,
you know, thanks so
much for doing this.
She actually has ADD.
This is actually
really hard for her,
for her to really pay
attention and find something
that she's interested
and passionate about,
so this is really great.
And so we built a
relationship with the parents.
And she kept coming
back to our programs
and wanting to learn more.
But I think the real
success is actually
when she stopped
coming to our programs,
and we reached out
to her parents.
And we're like,
hey, we miss you.
Our next workshop
is on this date.
Are you guys coming?
And each time, we would
get a different excuse.
And so it would be,
oh, we're so sorry.
She can't make it because
she's entering her first robot
in the science fair.
Or the next one we got
was, well, actually,
she's going to space
camp this summer.
And so the fact that we
were able to spark something
in her, that maybe she's not
going to be a programmer,
but she found something
that she's passionate about.
And our next girl who
also-- it sparked something
within her, as well-- she went
through one of our programs.
And she's been doing
iOS app development.
She was 12 when she wrote
our iOS app curriculum.
And she last year was
the youngest recipient
of a WWDC scholarship, the
Apple developers conference.
She had to have her
parents write in
because she didn't meet the
minimum age requirement of 13.
And so there's videos of
her with Tim Cook showing--
and she's really
deadpan, so it's
really funny to see her being
like, yeah, this is my app.
And he's like, wow!
This is amazing!
And you're like,
oh, OK, [? Kiera. ?]
So those to me are
the success stories.
And being able to
mentor those girls
and have that experience that I
didn't have when I was younger
really is what makes me do
what I do on the weekends.
I actually, after this,
have to go run and run
our girls program.
So that's why I do what I do.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
You want to--
SHANNA GREGORY: Yeah, yeah.
I'm so jealous that you get
to work with kids because I
work with adults.
And I love the adults.
And I think that it's a
very important message
to send to children--
you can do this.
You can build your iOS app.
You can figure out if you like
making video games or not.
And that's really,
really powerful.
But I think what I
really enjoy working
with adults is working with
people who are changing careers
so radically.
Some of them are coming
from design or electrical
engineering or architecture
and things that
are not quite so different.
But I also have
ceramicists, and I
have someone who curated art
museums and things like that,
who've always been
interested or figured out
that they were interested
in programming a little bit
too late-- too late meaning
in traditional education,
you need to make that
decision when you're about 18
to follow the right track
for your four-year education.
But people who are being able
to come back into our wonderful
fold that we have, coming
back and learning these skills
at a very different age.
You don't need to be 18
to pick up the skills.
You can be 45, and you can
have already had a career.
You could have
children and still
be able to learn these skills.
And I think building a
community that is inclusive,
but also, especially
age diversity
is pretty important in tech
and something that is lacking.
But it's great that we
can range through teaching
children and
encouraging children,
and especially young girls,
and then also kind of carry
that through and let
people know it's not
too late for them to join.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: I'm gonna
jump in here, if you don't mind.
So I had a conversation
probably about a month ago
with a friend of mine.
She's probably in her 30's.
And she says, Rose, you
know, you can't leave.
You can't leave tech because
you're getting too old.
And I was like, what
are you talking about?
She's like, well, because
you're just getting too old,
and there's not a lot of
opportunities for you.
I was like, well, I'm just
really getting started.
I have a lot of plans.
I have great experience
under my belt.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, thank you.
And I think my
path is leading me
to something a lot bigger
that I don't know right now.
But I certainly
applaud that, as well,
because I'm certainly not done.
And I learn a lot.
You all can learn a lot from me.
But one of the things also,
we, as Anita Borg Institute,
I know that it was mentioned
earlier--- our time to lead.
That really is very strong
and powerful, as well.
So we have the Grace
Hopper Celebration
for women in
computing every year.
But what happens is that, OK,
this three-day conference,
what's now?
What happens now?
So now we started-- we
launched five cities
of ABI.Local cities, which is
really trying to bring and add
to all of these other
wonderful groups
and bringing them together
and helping our own community.
So I live in Washington, DC.
But that is really very
Washington, DC-centric.
And so there's a lot
of great communities.
And I guess the makeup
of each is so different.
Like, the New York-- I attended
an ABI.New York event, as well.
And it was just phenomenal.
But DC, because we're
in the nation's capital,
there's a lot of policy work.
And so I get to learn more about
the policy and the technology.
So that's more where
our programs really
help women to
create opportunities
in their local communities,
because you don't really
hear about the women that are
in your local communities that
are contributing on
a very regular basis.
So making sure that story
is told at a local level
is what we do, as well.
So just wanted to
put that in there.
Saron, did you--
SARON YITBAREK: Just to
make sure I understand,
the question is, how has our
work impacted women in tech,
right?
OK So for me, it's
on two levels.
So for myself personally, one
of the things that I try to do
is be very aware
of who I connect
and who I recommend compared
to who other people are
trying to recommend.
So, for example, when I'm
on the programming committee
and we're trying
to pick keynotes
and I see who other
people are picking,
and they all kind of come
from-- they all look alike.
And so I go, OK, well, I need
to go the other direction.
And so I go out of my
way to find and make
sure to get really high-quality
people who are different--
again, going back to this idea
of showing inclusion and making
sure that all voices are heard.
So that applies
to speaker panels.
That applies to making
job introductions.
That applies to retweets.
I mean, really any way that
I can amplify and connect
someone, I try to do that.
And for CodeNewbie specifically,
one of the biggest joys that I
get is when I get emails
from people who say,
I know CodeNewbie isn't
a diversity thing,
but your lineup
is really diverse.
And it's just really
great to get to see people
from my country and who speak my
language and who look like me.
And I've just never
seen that before.
And so for me, that's
just the biggest
win because we don't push that.
We don't push the whole, look
at us, we're speaking to women.
We don't do that.
But to know that by
being very consistent
and being very inclusive
and welcoming, that people
are still receiving that message
and people feel validated
and people feel like
they have a place
at the table, that is one of
the biggest rewards we can get.
ROSARIO ROBINSON:
Yeah, thank you.
And Christina?
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Do I have
to answer this question?
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Yeah.
Yeah, I think we
still have time.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: So I'm
not a metrics-based person.
I don't like metrics,
for me, personally.
They make me feel limited.
And I don't like to walk
around, like, oh, yeah,
so I'm impacting everybody.
And everybody loves me.
And I'm the bomb.
No, no, no.
When it comes to
it, I'm very humble.
So I normally walk
around-- my days,
I don't feel like I'm
changing anybody's lives.
I'm just trying to create
a better life for myself
and my children and my family.
And I get reminders
that I'm impacting
when people come up to me at
different events and are like,
oh, hey, you're Christina.
It's so great to meet you.
And I'm like, um, yeah, hi.
But they make me
feel really good.
Like, oh, my god.
You're a superstar.
And I'm like, I'm just me.
And when they tell me their
stories-- like, because of you,
I changed careers.
Or because of you, I also have
two kids, or I'm a single mom.
And I know that I can do this.
Those are my metrics.
So I don't have accounts.
But I'm really just passionate
about people's stories
and listening to
people's stories,
whether it's on
Twitter or in person.
Knowing that I may
be contributing
to someone's self-esteem, but on
the other end of the spectrum,
they're helping me, as well.
So it's almost like
a mutual thing.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Yeah.
When you're helping, when you're
giving other opportunities
to other people, you're actually
helping yourself, as well.
So we're going to do
a Q and A session.
And I encourage you
all to say, hey, yes.
Come up.
So we have two mics, here
and on the other side here.
So if you want to come up and
ask any of us any questions
that you want, please feel free.
We have about five minutes
for the Q and A, maybe?
Two or three?
Five minutes?
10?
Oh, cool.
Cool, cool.
Very cool.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Give us
your name and what you do.
AUDIENCE: OK, I'm Maya.
I'm a business
intelligence developer
looking for opportunities.
SARON YITBAREK: Good for you.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: My question is, I was
sitting here for the last hour.
And I'm so much inspired by you.
But there are only
24 hours in a day.
How do you do that?
Some people with five kids.
I have one child.
How do you find the
time to be engaged
in all of the nonprofit
activities and inspiring others
and then do your
day job, and not
to mention the house
and the family?
ROSARIO ROBINSON: So
I'll take that one, too.
Very little sleep.
No, I'm just kidding.
But this is what Heather
mentioned earlier--
find your passion, right?
I had great opportunities.
It was lots of challenges due to
the gender factor and the race
factor.
But I have an African
American daughter
who's majoring in
computer science
and an African American son
who's majoring in economics.
I don't want them to have to
go through what I went through.
I mean, this is 2016.
We should be so further along
than where we are right now.
[APPLAUSE]
But I have-- thank you.
And I'm sure that everyone
here is sharing that, as well.
We have to do something.
And this is my passion.
I want my kids-- and now my
niece has two kids, also.
What are we going to
do, just leave it up
to their generations, as well?
It's something we have to
do as a whole, as a group,
as women, as minorities.
CHRISTINA MORILLO:
Help each other.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Yeah.
We have to help each other.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Yeah.
Can I just take this, as well?
That's a really great question,
because people are always
talking about balance.
And I don't believe in balance.
That's a lie.
Balance is a myth.
Unless you're balancing
something on your head,
it's a lie.
So for me, it's
really about purpose.
So to be really
honest in this room--
and do not tweet this 'cause
I will deny it-- my day job
doesn't give me purpose.
But my evening activities
give me purpose.
Being a part of the
CodeNewbie community,
being a part of the Women of
Color in Tech Chat community,
working on all of
these initiatives,
chatting with Natalie, the
head of Woman Techmakers,
and meeting all these amazing
people, that gives me purpose.
And that is better than a
Red Bull, which I do drink.
But--
AUDIENCE: Love is
the great motivator.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Yeah.
It's just purpose.
I'm not going to lie.
Most of the time, I'm tired.
I'm exhausted.
I have makeup on because
I don't want people
to see my bags under my eyes.
But it's almost like I'm willing
to give that because it makes
me feel like I'm contributing
to something, to a greater good.
So not too much sleep,
a supportive husband.
I don't have much
family around me.
It's just really my husband and
I. So We try to do what we can.
Sometimes kids miss school
because I have a early meeting
or something.
Saturdays, they're
like, where you going?
Now they're like, are you going
to a conference or to work?
And I'm like-- and
my four-year-old.
And I'm like, I'm
going to a conference.
She's like, OK, I see you later.
But it's also for
my girls and my son
to see that there's more than
fitting into this little box
and having to do this routine.
There's more.
You can break out of that.
So that's what drives me.
But it's not easy.
SARON YITBAREK: Can I take
a stab at that, as well?
So for me, I think
that-- so first of all,
let me preface this by
saying I'm not a parent.
I don't have kids.
I don't understand how
Christina's-- and, you know,
I don't understand
how that works.
So much respect for all
the work that you do.
I have a husband.
He's generally self-sufficient.
That's all I have to deal with.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'll preface it with that.
But having said
that, for me, there
was a big kind of mind-set shift
that I had a couple months ago
where I stopped saying,
I don't have time for it,
and I started saying, this
isn't important enough.
And so for me, it
wasn't about how many
hours do I have in a day.
It was about is this
thing important enough
to fit into my limited time.
And so I started cutting
out a lot of activities.
I hate cooking.
I just-- no, not me.
I tried the Blue
Apron thing once.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: She
cooks really good, though.
SARON YITBAREK: That
one time, just for you.
But otherwise-- my husband
doesn't even get that.
And so for me, I do meal prep.
I spend one to two hours a week.
I organize all my meals.
I have my lunch.
I have my little oatmeal
in a little plastic bag,
and my berries in another bag.
And I will not give more than
two hours a week on cooking.
I just won't do it.
It's not worth my time.
I'm sorry.
Even things like
going out, I try
to prioritize and re-prioritize.
Every single day, I have
a very long to-do list,
and I re-prioritize
that to-do list.
I rewrite it every single day.
I have a notebook
full of each day.
And I break it down into these
are the things that really need
to get done today and will
have a huge impact on the goals
that I want to meet.
And then these are the
things that are easy to do,
that are quick to do, but
aren't actually that impactful.
And for me, when I was able
to split those two lists
and really focus on the things
that might take four hours
but will get me much
further compared
to responding to a
bunch of emails that
will make other people happy
but aren't really reaching
my goals, when I was able
to focus on that big list,
that really, really helped
me a lot more productive.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank
you very much.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
And I want to get through a
lot of the questions, as well.
So one question over here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Oh, that's very loud.
I'm gonna stand back.
And I'm already loud enough.
Hi.
I really can't speak enough
about how much I just
love wonderful women coming
together and banding together.
It's one of the
biggest things that I
support in the community
at large, and inclusion
and diversity.
One of the things I
want to do, especially
because you talked so much about
it because it was wonderful--
but the photos, how can
we contribute to that?
Because if you can't
see it, you can't be it.
And I'm a big believer in that.
And I don't want
my nieces to think
they're weird because they're
I'm sending them a computer.
You're going to learn to code.
They're like, what?
I want them be like, oh, no.
There's 1,000 pictures online.
It's fine.
Just do it.
So how can we be part of that?
How can we help that message?
Is there a way that
we can upload things?
Because I run a
program for it, and I
know many other women who
run women-lead programs that
are just-- let's help.
Let's get this out there.
And I think you're right.
Photos are so powerful
in that respect.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: That might
be a white elephant opportunity,
actually.
AUDIENCE: I would
love to help out.
I've got a camera.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: So we can
definitely talk after this.
But I've been
thinking about ways
to make it more-- because it
was a three-series initiative.
So we've completed
the series, and we
have two new batches of
photos that will be uploaded.
But I've heard this before.
So they're open source.
By the way, the photos are
100% free on a Creative Commons
attribution license.
You just have to give us
a little mini-shout-out.
But they're free.
Anybody can use
them, any company.
We don't charge.
The goal was never to
make money on the photos.
So I have to think about
that, because maybe this
can be something a little
bit bigger than what it is.
AUDIENCE: If you're at Civic
Hall ever, I'll just grab you.
CHRISTINA MORILLO:
Or you can find her
because she can find me, too.
She's at Civic Hall.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
And I have an idea, too.
And so we should talk more.
Hi.
Welcome.
AUDIENCE: How you doing?
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Good.
AUDIENCE: I'm Christina.
I'm from Morgan Stanley.
I'm not actually a coder.
I actually do stuff
with physical security.
So I deal with hardware
and software and people.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: Christine,
don't snitch on me.
AUDIENCE: I promise.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: I didn't
put this through OBI.
Don't snitch on me.
AUDIENCE: I promise.
We are all in this together.
What happens here, stays here.
So I had my own white
elephant experience
to get into my career.
I had the flu.
My boss at the
time was a jackass.
We didn't have insurance
that we were being paid for.
I was 19 years old.
And I was basically lambasted
for being sick for two days.
So I went back to my desk.
I wrote "I quit" on a piece of
paper, stuck a pen in the wall,
out the door I went.
I was working for a
cruise travel agency.
It was nothing to
do with where I was.
And I took the opportunity.
I said, gee, I
have bills to pay.
I've got a car payment
due in three days.
And don't know that
waitressing's going
to get that to me that weekend.
So that Monday, I found
myself in a temp job
for one day, which
turned into my career.
So I found myself
in a situation where
I didn't know where I was
headed and found opportunities
while there.
I was working for AT&T. And
the management team there
found ways to--
they saw, I guess,
a spark that I was
interested in learning.
So it turned into the
career I have today.
So today, I'm interested
in, obviously,
also creating white
elephant opportunities
for women in tech and also in
the physical security industry.
Similar to the technology
world, in physical security,
a lot of it is retired police,
retired government officials,
which is very heavy in the
men's side of the world.
So when you find yourself
talking to security folks,
probably even here at Google,
very well many of them
are going to be men, especially
in the leadership roles.
So I'm lucky in the
opportunity that I have.
I'm a director.
So I have several
women that work for me.
One of them has moved
on, and she actually
had an opportunity
in another company,
and I was very excited for her.
So the thing I
struggle with now is
how to not only
create and represent
opportunities for them to
learn about technology,
but to show them they can trust
that this is something that's
going to continue forward.
Because there's a
lot of times there's
still that fear and
that stigma that I'm
sure we all experience.
What is the statistic?
It's like one woman to
four in the industry.
And it's hard to sometimes
still perpetuate the message.
And I'm going to be 40 soon.
And I find that while I'm
ready and able to move forward,
it's hard sometimes to excite
some of the younger folks
to still take that step, to
enlighten them and incite them
that there is a future
here and it's exciting.
Do any of you guys have
situations in your past
that would help to find the
path to take those first steps?
You all talked very excitedly
about what you're doing today
and how you kind of got there.
But what's the
first memory for you
that made you see,
gee, this is something
I'm doing that's different,
and it does have a purpose,
and I'm going to do
something someday with photos
and be very exciting?
But how do you instill
that excitement
to have women come
along to trust?
ROSARIO ROBINSON: And I'm just
going to butt in here, as well,
is that this is going to
have to be the last question.
But all of us will be
around the whole entire day.
So please find us.
Ask us anything that you want.
And I apologize that we
can't get to everyone.
But we got to keep
to time, as well.
So any one person wants
to answer that question?
SARON YITBAREK: Yeah, I'd
love to answer that one.
So one of my first memories
of being the person who
wasn't really sure
what I wanted to do
and was kind of afraid
of taking the first steps
and having someone encourage
me-- her name is Vanessa Hurst.
If you all don't know who she,
she started Girl Develop It.
Absolutely amazing, one
of my biggest heroes,
really important mentor, really
important person in my life.
And she had a meetup.
And she said, let's
all come together.
And let's all talk
about conference talks.
And let's talk about
what topics you
might want to propose
for a future conference.
And I said, sure, great.
No idea what to expect.
Let's go do this.
And it ended up being me, her,
and just one other person.
And we were sitting at a table.
And I think at that
point, I was a month out
of my programming bootcamp,
just learned how to code.
I think I'd just started a job
at that point, felt totally
unqualified to speak to anyone
about anything related to tech.
And I pitched this idea
about a reading code group
that my friends and I did.
For every Saturday
for one hour, we
got together and read code
as a way of developing
our programming skills.
And I pitched it to her, and I
thought it was a terrible idea.
I thought no one would ever
be interested in hearing
about this.
And she said, no, you
should definitely do it.
And I said, OK.
Well, if Vanessa Hurst
thinks it's good, then
maybe there's some value.
And I said, but do you think
I should shop it around
at meetups and kind
of smaller places
first before pitching it
to-- this was for RailsConf.
So it was the big conference.
And she looked at
me, and she goes,
I don't believe in
stepping stones.
And I was like, oh, my god.
And that has been
my motto ever since.
It's been, OK, do
I want to do this?
Or do I want to try
this other thing first?
And then I hear
Vanessa's voice go,
I don't believe in
stepping stones.
And I go for the big thing.
That was the first talk I
proposed, and I got accepted.
And I've given that talk
about 10 to 12 times
all over the world since
then in the last two years.
And I've gotten paid
to give that talk.
And so it's been a huge, huge
moment for me in my career.
And so what I've
learned from that
is to be that voice
for other people.
And so a lot of times, I'll
hear someone tell a story,
and I'll go, that's be a
really good conference talk.
And I'll say to them,
hey, did you ever
think about pitching that
and submitting a CFP?
And they'll go, no, I don't
really think it's good enough.
And I haven't really
done it that long.
And I'll yell at them.
I really will.
And I'll pull them
aside, and I'll go, no.
That is amazing.
And I'll give them facts.
And that's the thing.
I think that people don't really
appreciate their own skills
until they hear
someone else say it.
And so I'll say, no, you've
been doing this for three years.
You have a very
interesting story.
We need voices like you.
And I give them a pitch of how
you would structure the story
and kind of give them
something to work with.
And I'll say, submit it.
If you want, I'm
happy to review it.
And I'll pester
them until they do.
Christina knows.
I've sent text
messages late at night.
I'll do whatever I need to do.
And eventually, they do it.
And then they get picked.
And they come back
to me, and they go,
I never would have taken that
step if you hadn't pushed.
So I'm very comfortable being
the mama bear of the situation.
I'm very comfortable pushing
you if I believe in you.
And I think that for a lot of
women and men that I've helped,
it's been me being that very
persistent voice, saying,
you are good enough, and you do
know what you're talking about.
And the worst case
scenario is they'll say no,
and you're in the exact
same situation you'd
be in if you hadn't applied.
So what's the worst
that can happen?
And I think being that
has been really helpful.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
Appreciate it.
And we probably
have-- lunch is here.
So we're going to
serve-- yeah, go ahead.
Clap.
So we have a final round,
final advice that you
want to leave everyone with.
So do you want to start, Saron?
SARON YITBAREK:
Yeah, I'll start.
Sure.
So the biggest advice
that I have-- so
I gave a talk at ELA Conf in
Philly a couple months ago.
And the talk was titled
"Punching Your Feelings
in the Face."
And the talk is about how I
feel like a lot of people--
and I see this more
with women, but I'll
say I think everyone feels
this way at some point.
We wait until we feel
good to do something.
We wait until we
feel comfortable.
We wait until we feel like
things are just right.
We just wait,
expecting the feeling
to come and have all these
good feelings come before we
actually take that step.
And a huge, huge
thing in my career
has been being afraid, being
terrified, feeling totally
unqualified to apply for that
job or to be on this panel
or to do whatever it
is, but doing it anyway.
Feeling good and
feeling comfortable
is not a prerequisite
for action.
And so the biggest advice I have
for you is if you're afraid,
that's OK.
You can be afraid
and click Submit.
You can.
So please take action and don't
let your feelings hold you
back.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SHANNA GREGORY: I just want
to reiterate everything that
has been said at this point.
I feel like I don't have
anything novel to contribute
to this advice because
everything that Heather has
said in her white
elephant talk, everything
that Saron just shared about
being afraid and feeling
like you're not good
enough to be on this panel,
some people felt like
that coming up here.
But there really
is nothing to lose.
And that's true.
What is the worst case scenario?
Sometimes it doesn't
help to think about that.
But honestly, if the worst case
scenario is someone telling
you no or you're not
going to get the job
or you're not going to do
that, you are still yourself
and you still have those skills.
You can still try again.
And definitely, if you
are in a position where
you can support
other people, do that
as much as humanly possible.
Do that hiring or having
more inclusive panels or more
inclusive teams.
That's really important.
The woman who just asked a
question, she's a director.
She has people underneath her.
She's in that position where
you can support your other women
that you're working with.
But you can also have
very frank conversations
with people who are a detriment
to those women, as well.
So don't be afraid to
extend the conversation
past these wonderful
people in this room.
Share that with everyone.
I think that's the biggest
thing I have to contribute.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: Thank you.
REBECCA GARCIA: So one of the
quotes that stayed with me
for a while from an author
I like called Jon Acuff--
J-O-N A-C-U-F-F. He writes
really great inspirational
books on getting started,
on just getting things done.
And what's really, really
stuck with me is along
the same lines of
having imposter syndrome
or kind of getting caught
off of how do I get there?
CHRISTINA MORILLO: I
quote her all the time.
REBECCA GARCIA: My favorite
quote, our favorite quote is,
don't compare your beginning
to someone else's middle.
Because it's very
easy to do that.
I've been doing
the nonprofit thing
on the side for four years now.
And it's been a long journey.
And it starts somewhere.
And it starts with that
small spark of whatever
it is you're passionate about.
And it doesn't have to
be teaching kids to code.
It doesn't have to be this
big, grand gesture of changing
the world, but knowing
that what you're doing,
however small it is,
makes a difference.
CHRISTINA MORILLO: I
love that quote so much.
Oh, my god.
OK, so that quote, plus just
remember the anger activates.
So just remember that.
Anger activates.
But use it in a positive way.
So anger activates positively.
And number two is
don't follow the crowd.
If everyone is learning to code,
and if you don't like code,
don't learn to code.
It's fine.
It's OK.
Learn something else.
The tech ecosystem
is huge, and there's
so many different positions
that people don't talk about.
And I think it's important
to get out there.
If you don't want to
go to a meetup, fine.
Go on Twitter.
Read up on things.
Meet people that are in
different-- QA analysts
or information
security architects.
There's so many positions out
there that don't necessarily
involve code.
And although I
always support people
that want to learn
another language,
because it's kind of
like another language,
I'm very big on-- I'm a lover
of education and learning,
whether it's
self-taught or whatever.
So I think just don't follow
the crowd, and just do you.
Just remember to do you.
Don't worry about what
other people are doing.
Don't compare yourself.
And don't give yourself
this stress for no reason.
Just follow your own path.
Create your own path.
And I think that's the
most important thing.
ROSARIO ROBINSON: So I
say that all the time.
I tell my kids, you do you.
Don't worry about
what's going on.
And incidentally, my
background and my expertise
is in infrastructure.
So while all the
apps are being made,
just know that
their infrastructure
needs to happen to
support that, as well.
But remember the theme of
today is our time to lead.
And you have to trust yourself.
Start with that.
Trust yourself.
You're here for a reason.
You're present in this
industry for a reason.
So take that to heart,
and go out and lead.
And we appreciate it.
And thank you so much
for your time today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]